mais d'abord c'est une des pistes sur la
table examinée selon les dernières infos
lors du prochain conseil de défense
sanitaire prévue lundi prochain un
renforcement des frontières pour éviter
une plus forte propagation du virus
l'idée
circulent et elle est notamment défendue
par le porte-parole du gouvernement
gabriel attal la france elle a un cadre
de restrictions à ses frontières qui est
parmi les plus fermes en europe et très
tôt et d'ailleurs quand on regarde la
reprise de l'épidémie liée aux variants
delta dans certains pays européens
je pense au portugal ou à l'espagne
c'est des pays qui pour le coup avait
assoupli le cadre de leurs frontières
notamment avec le royaume-uni beaucoup
plus tôt que nous et nous on a gardé ce
cadre là mais encore une fois on a un
cadre qui est parmi les plus
restrictives en europe et on a pris des
mesures parmi les pays est plutôt en
europe al'inverse voici le point de vue
du président du conseil scientifique
jean françois delfraissy
écoutez je crois que c'est déjà trop
tard des mesures ont été prises un sur
sur l'arrivée des vols depuis longtemps
depuis plus de six semaines
nous l'avions recommandé provenant
d'inde mais le virus indien est déjà
présent france il est présent bien déjà
un niveau de pourcentage qui qui va
augmenter
vincent vous êtes d'accord avec les
briatta jean françois delfraissy
j'ai du mal à m'y retrouver puisque en
même temps ce matin crémant bonne a
expliqué qu'il y avait des endroits où
on ne vais pas aller
donc d'un côté le président c'est
scientifique dit au fait
finalement les frontières ça ne compte
plus puisque le variant delta est là et
c'est trop tard et d'autres nous indique
qu'il faut faire attention moi je
pensais des réflexes de bon sens le
premier c'est d'essayer de faire en
sorte de savoir est ce que des gens
malades arrivent ou pas sur le
territoire français ça se fait quand
même de plus en plus dans les aéroports
et ça se fait de la même façon quand on
on va à l'étranger après ça n'arrêtera
rien là sous ce qu'on comprend avec ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que
cette version du virus est très
contagieuse mais qu'il est possible
qu'elle ne soit pas aussi agressive pour
le système hospitalier français parce
qu'il ya une partie de la population
importante 35% des français qui sont
vaccinées l'on dit que c'est pas
suffisant mais c'est quand même 35 % de
plus que l'année dernière à la même
époque on peut rajouter je pense un
pourcentage qui de 15 % de gens qui ont
eu comme idée qui n'ont pas encore été
vaccinés
donc ça fait 1 français sur 2 partir de
là ça fait quand même un certain nombre
d'obstacles pour que le virus se propage
plus fin pour un livre voilà moi moi moi
entraide une vague tel qu'on l'a décrit
donc moi il me semble qui alla dans le
discours quelque chose de contradictoire
et à mon avis d'une erreur de ton de la
part de l'exécutif qui est de jouer la
peur et de jouer le fait qu'on subit
alors on subit et si on vaccine c'est à
dire à moi j'aurais été partisan d'une
communication beaucoup plus positive
c'est-à-dire une espèce de deux
d'accompagnement peu médiatique de
l'épopée du vaccin quasiment comme un
mouvement patriotique collectif disant
que
si on continue sur ce rythme à la fin on
arriverait à empêcher cette quatrième
vague je pense qu'on prend et depuis le
début on joue l'anxiété comme une
politique volontaire et il me semble que
c'est pas sain et d'ailleurs on voit que
dans la confusion des esprits
aujourd'hui ce cette pratique de la peur
joue beaucoup c'est à dire que des gens
ne croient plus n'ont plus peur de virus
ou fait pour aller vite et donc ne croit
plus les pouvoirs publics
c'est un effet d'un an et demi de
pratique systématique de d'une
rhétorique bavarde et anxiogène 20 ans
vincent a déjà dit beaucoup de choses
moi je pense qu'avant votre point de vue
sur cette rhétorique bavarde cox la
peine en ce qui concerne le variant
delta ce qui est important c'est que on
a déjà vécu plusieurs épisodes de
variants etc en fait à chaque fois qu'il
ya un variant quand vous êtes vacciné ce
qui est par exemple mon cas vous dites
mais alors à quoi ça a servi et donc il
faut faire très attention dans le dans
la rhétorique justement je pas si elle
est bavarde mais a bien expliqué que ce
être vaccinés ça a servi à quelque chose
c'est à dire que face à ces différents
variant vous êtes en tout cas protéger
des formes graves donc je trouve qu'au
moins 1 gabriela talent aurait pu
rappeler que se vacciner et certainement
beaucoup moins dangereux que de que
d'avoir le virus est encore plus sous
une forme une forme dangereuse et une
forme inconnue il ya encore quelques
mois
c'est assez le problème c'est à dire que
quand j'écoute gabriela talent j'entends
parler de contrôler les frontières au
fond de regarder qui arrivent sur le
territoire sans donner le sentiment
qu'on est les instruments au fond les
instruments scientifiques les
instruments de santé publique pour
contenir le virus alors que nous les
avons nous avons et aussi nous l'avons
très bons hôpitaux et face à au
scepticisme vaccinale qui au fond chaque
jour et démontrer et qui existent
notamment chez les soignants mais aussi
chez les catégories de la population qui
sont relativement âgés
moi je vois beaucoup de jeunes qui se
vaccinent mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des gens de mon âge
par exemple qui refuse de se vacciner au
motif qu'on n'a pas la distance
suffisante et bien au fur et à mesure
qu'on communique mal et je d'accord avec
vincent et qu'on est anxiogène sur les
nouveaux variants onze idéal et à delta
qui arrive mais il va ya là encore un
autre
à quoi bon se faire vacciner donc
l'essentiel cedr a affirmé qu'il est
essentiel de se vacciner
et puis que quelque part on va vaincre
ces choses n'ont pas en disant mais on
est le meilleur gouvernement par rapport
aux espagnols aux portugais mais en dix
ans peut-être qu'on a le meilleur
système de santé qu'on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour se vacciner qu'on a de bons
médecins etc donc d'autres arguments
devraient être utilisés et quand
delfraissy moi je pense que déprécier
raison ça
que quelque part aujourd'hui le variant
circulent et que mais il devrait dire le
variant circule donc vacciner vous c'est
ça qui me semblent manquer étrangement
c'est à dire qu'on a une discussion sur
l'état de la situation sans avoir de
véritables propositions opérationnelles
sur qu'est-ce que je fais si j'ai peur
d'attraper le virus ne vous trouvez pas
que quand même le justement le message
vaccinez vous c'est quand même un
message maintenant qui est martelée de
façon je trouve qu'il émargeait clair
ben je trouve qu'il est martelée d'une
manière qui n'est pas il est trés
martelé mais qu'il n'est pas convaincant
et je ne sais pas comment est ce qu'il
faudrait faire je sais pas s'il faudrait
faire du patriotisme je pense qu'il
faudrait peut-être en tout cas mettre en
avant des profils extrêmement différents
et des motivations pour se vacciner qui
peuvent être tout simplement de pouvoir
circuler de pouvoir vivre de pouvoir
faire confiance en la science est
peut-être mettre à disposition pour cela
une diversité de parole et conçoit pas
avec le sentiment que le gouvernement
jean castex nous exhorte à nous faire
vacciner
c'est quelque chose qui ne prend pas
dans la population il faudrait peut-être
d'abord faire un peu de communication
puisqu'on a des budgets énormes pour
faire une communication très souvent
c'est parce que fait le gouvernement
non enfin si vous regardez un peu on va
prendre des exemples on prend l'exemple
américain il ya un clip dans lequel il
ya de george w bush bill clinton et
barack obama qui discute après s'être
fait vacciner
et tout ça et dans une ambiance très
américaine ils sont formidables il ya un
an
ils sont beaux ils sont beaux et je
pense que l'américain garde ça se dit
j'ai envie de faire comme je n'ai pas vu
de mobilisation de trois jours de
carence d'une grande comédienne de d'un
grand chef d'entreprise et de
le l'inépuisable thomas pesquet pour
dire aux gens alesi l'on n'a pas vu et
on a vu le breton n'a vu le bras
d'olivier vers oui et après il ya quand
même une maj comment il ya un modèle
vraiment là de pratiques politiques dans
ces moments sanitaires sur plan
politique peut-être qu'il aura tort
l'effet d'une orientation pour sanitaire
c'est le discours fait pas si vous avez
le temps de le regarder de bruit johnson
annonçant que malgré la progression du
virus
il laisserait les choses réouvrir parce
que la vaccination est l arbre et il y
avait des mots qu'on n'entende plus
jamais il a eu le mot de conscience il
dit il faut que vous réfléchissiez en
conscience à l'attitude que vous devez
avoir que ce soit dans le port du masque
vaccins etc
les mots de responsabilité l'éloge de la
liberté et surtout et c'est ça qui m'a
paru très intelligent c'est à dire qu'
il n'y ni n'est pas rester dans un cadre
où c'est soit l'enfermement un peu
beaucoup passionnément il a dit
maintenant c'est terminé on peut plus
vivre comme ça il a dit quelles sont les
possibilités où on re confine et on n'en
sort jamais ou repousse et quand on va
ouvrir ce sera l'hiver et ce sera pire
donc maintenant on tente et on vit avec
et la liberté doit exister en même temps
qu'une politique vaccinale dynamique et
qu'une pratique personnelle prudente et
responsable
ça me paraît quand même plus éloquent et
puis c'est lui qui parle c'est par un de
ses ministres c'est par des
représentants de la santé c'est lui pour
le moment
castex est inaudible et on n'a pas
entendu le président de la république
sur cette question qui devrait peut-être
alors il va peut-être le faire mais le
faron dois bien dire
le frère encore une fois avec solennité
et avec ce souffle que mme johnson a
voulu montrer où la liberté l'a emporté
sur l'inquiétude dans son propos non je
pense que ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'il faut rappeler que boris
johnson a eu le coronavirus est allé à
l'hôpital et a été dans un état grave et
avant d'expérimenter la maladie il
n'était pas du tout une relation de
faire ce discours de responsabilité donc
il ya là quelque chose qui nous éclaire
aussi sur la façon dont ce qui vous
arrive dans la
il vous aide aussi à faire de la
politique la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire c'est que il faut peut-être
s'habituer à vivre avec le virus ou
peut-être la succession des biens russes
au fond c'est ça que nous disent les
différents variant mais du coup il faut
s'habituer à penser que nous sommes
capables de résister à ces virus non pas
avec les frontières mais avec la science
la médecine est quelque part en mettant
les choses en commun donc moi je suis
contre cette vision des frontières qu'on
ferme
je suis sur l'idée qu'il faut au
contraire avoir une approche assez
offensive et où grâce à la médecine
grâce à la coopération
grâce à l'argent qu'on mettra dans la
santé publique on réussir à résister à
d'autres pandémies je crois qu'il faut
aussi avoir un discours de vision la
suivent l'installation d'une frontière
cognitive dans chacun des esprits
vis-à-vis de la formation compulsive qui
installe participe de cette anxiété
souvent un exemple tout bête le variant
delta augmente on trouve une politique
vaccinale on a compris que ça pouvait
marcher
on dit qu'il ya un frémissement pour les
premières doses qui qui qui se fait jour
et puis là dessus on fait une alerte
pour dire que le variant lambda en
californie peut-être résiste pas au
freezer bon alerte qu'on a entendues sur
le variant brésilien qu'ont entendu sur
le variant sud africain tout ça n'est
pas hiérarchiser tout ça est et je pense
pour un esprit normal quand même bien
que le vôtre c'est insupportable en fait
il ya un moment il faut se créer une
espèce de fun spes d'athlètes intérieur
quoi pour se dire bon là je fais le tri
là ça n'est pas intéressant et qu'est-ce
que dans la vie quotidienne dans ma vie
sociale dans ma vie familiale je dois
savoir pour réagir mais sinon on est
devant une information totale permanente
devant laquelle nous sommes impuissants
et 7,6 yves ouais il ya quelque chose
dedans mon avis période
psychologiquement et et
il vous posez pas de problème de
l'information en général parce que c'est
oui mais dans ce cas particulier
il me semble mais je pense que
l'information permanente n'est pas une
bonne chose pour l'esprit elle est une
bonne chose quand elle compte notamment
chez nous parce que les hiérarchiser
mais mais mais il faut là il faut la
pratiquer de façon mesurée mais je crois
que dans cette histoire comme la peur
président depuis le début et que
l'inconnu et là aussi puisque il se
passe des choses que l'on n'a pas prévu
il ya une espèce de tentations sur la
vire je vois aussi par exemple moi je
n'ai entendu sur les plateaux de
télévision j'ai été où je les lui dans
ses papiers
la comparaison entre l'été 2021 ils
étaient 2000 26 ans revit la même chose
c'est l'éternel retour se paye tous là
une chose on n'avait pas de vaccin il ya
un an on ne savait même pas non mais on
est plus détendu à moi que jamais on
n'avait pas vécu autant de variantes
dont je pense qu'on était persuadé qu'on
s'en étaient tirés willow par le jeu et
revenir sur clame pardonnez-moi sur le
sur le thème de cette partie sur la
question des frontières parce qu'il ya
des commentaires voulait dire qu'elle
s'en écarter je dis que c'était ce que
vous avez dit tout à fait intéressant
mais effectivement le thème est offert
aux frontières dans qu'arthur nous
disent le variant circulent déjà
activement l'erreur a été de rouvrir les
frontières pour l'été et joël nous dit
sans parler de renforcement aux
frontières un réel contrôle serait déjà
un grand pas je passe plusieurs fois la
frontière voitures chaque mois sans
jamais être contrôlés vous parlais tout
à l'heure de clément boat et d'après nos
confrères du canard enchaîné en tous les
cas il a remarqué que landais
dernièrement en cas roissy il n'y avait
aucun contrôle
ce qui aurait provoqué la colère du
président de la république qui aurait
donné des instructions pour que ce soit
modifiée est ce que quand même il n'ya
pas égal quand même un problème mais
c'est un aspect du problème jeu
je lui dis au début je pense que ça
règlerait pas le problème mais il est
tout à fait normal d'abord on va aller
un sujet qui va au delà du coc vide il
serait normal qu'un pays sage qui rentre
et qui sort dans son pays ce n'est pas
monstrueux c'est la règle et ensuite il
est tout à fait naturel de faire en
sorte que des gens malades
et qui peuvent diffuser l'infection
n'arrive pas sur le territoire national
et donc il ya des protocoles il ya des
règles par exemple le mois il se trouve
que j'ai eu la chance et le bonheur d'il
ya quinze jours d'aller encore ce bon
c'est une île mais c'est absolument en
france elle est en france c'est une
ville à jamais
lll et a parfaitement organisé pour ce
que nous nous exposons là c'est à dire
qu'on ne rend on voit des gens se faire
refouler parce qu'ils n'ont pas leur
test ou que leurs tests à 5 heures de
trop et s'il faut être soit vaccinée
soit avoir un test anti phoenix soit
avoir un thé spécial et la vertu en plus
de cette frontière dans la frontière qui
est le test ou qu'elle passe c'est qu'il
entraînait les gens sur vacciner c'est à
dire que notamment c'est pour ça que les
jeunes y vont se disent bon allez moi je
vais allé plusieurs fois dans des pays
d'europe plutôt que refaire tout cet
exercice je vais me faire vacciner comme
ça après tout je peux passer plus plus
facilement nathan nous dit fermer les
frontières confiné n'est ce pas
transformer la france en vaste ehpad
et charles sceptique je ne pense pas que
la communication puisse infléchir les
résolutions de ceux qui refusent la
vaccination qui secoue justement
répondre à ça c'est ce qu'ils disent
sociologue a d'ailleurs ce matin dans le
figaro jérémie voir qui se sont expédia
lisez dans les attitudes face au vaccin
qui explique qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes non vaccinées mais qui ne sont
pas opposées au vaccin et va même
jusqu'à dire si ces personnes se vaccine
on n'arrivera sans doute à un nombre
suffisant de personnes vaccinées pour
une immunité collective d'accord non je
pense que les gens qui sont anti anti
vaccin ça on le sait je pense que
l'appel à la responsabilité collective a
évidemment peut créer une dynamique chez
ces gens qui sont sceptiques et je pense
que le scepticisme vis-à-vis de ce
vaccin là ces vaccins là sur le colis
est évidemment liée au manque de recul
c'est à dire que il reprit y compris
chez les soignants ça et je crois que
vous l'avez dit vin sont donc ça c'est
un vrai sujet il ya peut-être une prise
de risque un peu différente par rapport
à ce vaccin puisque a pas de recul
après on peut considérer aussi que le
risque pandémique aujourd'hui est un
risque comme on n'en avait jamais vécu
et qu ainsi on fait si on ne se
vaccinent pas d'abord on se compte on se
condamne à ne pas bouger de chez soi je
pense que vivre cette c'est un risque
quelque part et puis la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il faut appeler à la
responsabilité collective vis-à-vis de
ceux avec lesquels on est en contact et
c'est donc moi je suis sensible à ce que
disait vincent / boris johnson tout
simplement parce que c'est pas un
discours de boris johnson ces indices
nous on doit tous avoir en démocratie
sur le discours sur la vaccination
peut-être que pas trop de discours mais
en revanche des discussions pas trop de
discours idéologique ou pas trop de
culpabilisation et en retranchant le
score en europe
non mais en revanche moi c'est vrai que
je suis favorable à l'idée d'une
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants parce que je pense que ça fait
partie quelque part de la responsabilité
professionnelle
je pense que ça c'est différent
lorsqu'on et soignants parce qu'on prend
des risques de contaminer les malades et
je pense que ça c'est comme ça ça c'est
c'est c'est une particularité évidemment
lorsqu'on est en réunion on va être
d'accord mais c'est quand même effarant
de mettre des semaines arriver à ça
alors qu'on a 10 à 11 heures du soir
au mois de mars ya un an et demi aux
restaurateurs dans deux heures c'est
fermé et c'est fermé pour des mois et là
il ya quelque chose de deux complètement
paradoxal et de et de disproportionnées
ensuite sous le discours sur les vaccins
je pense que par hermine est sûre ça le
la pratique de la crâne 10 en mêlée il
ya des patients de plus en plus jeunes
mais l'écho vide l'on fait attention
c'est pas ça c'est pas la vérité c'est
que c'est un vaccin sociale c'est à dire
que les gens qui vont se faire vacciner
ne se disent pas ou je ne vais pas avoir
le coc vide je pense la plupart ils se
disent bon ben il passera pas par moi et
donc le désordre le dérèglement social
que ça entraîne et l'embolie de
l'hôpital qui fait que depuis un an de
traite plus que les patients qu'aux vide
et donc il ya des gens qui repoussent
leurs soins depuis un an et donc ça a
des conséquences aussi dramatiques pour
ces personnes là c'est ça et donc ça il
faut alors pour le coup le slogan de que
vers ans a trouvé à me paraît pas du
tout idiot quand il dit le vaccin est
efficace à 95% contre le virus à 100%
contre le confinement c'est de la vérité
c'est ça et ça elle devait à deux ça
aurait dû être dit dès le début parce
que le la peur de la maladie elle-même
n'est plus du tout la même qu'il ya un
an le nombre de rendez-vous d'ailleurs
est en train de décoller dit olivier
ferrand aujourd'hui dit il c'est une
bonne nouvelle
on va regarder juste la réponse à la
question que vous posez sur sur twitter
faut-il des renforcements aux frontières
pour lutter contre le variant delta et
stopper la nouvelle vague de covin 10,9
et vous êtes largement favorable à cette
mesure